[Music]
fashion
is
subject for today
that was a less aggressive sip followed
by a more aggressive sip
it's like lulling you into a state of
complacency
like the election fraud
fraud week we continue fraud week today
we'll be talking about georgia
exclusively because they're doing a
half-ass recount commonly known as a
fraud
fraudulent fraud recount commonly
so yeah commonly this is how it's known
in pedestrian society
so we talking about that will be talking
about uh joseph biden's executive order
and for giving student loans oh
good um and we'll also be talking about
all the politicians who have uh
obviously right now they've enacted uh
mandates and crazy lockdowns and
they don't follow them again of course
uh but uh right now we have in third
chair uh dave landau from compound media
how are you sir
good how about you man thank you
terrible i am terrible but not as bad as
audio waves face look at him
he has an infection going on no i got
like bee sting
later later we should all poke it yeah
it happened to be on the camera side too
so oh
of course well i can't see it quarter
black carrot
gerald a i hope you're doing well we
have so much to get to that i don't
really care
so before we move on this is just just
talk about
virtue signaling in someone who is ju an
insufferable ass senator
rod brown but i repeat myself here he is
yesterday demanding that his colleagues
uh wear masks president senator from
ohio i'd start by asking the presiding
officer to please wear a mask
as he speaks and people below him or i
can't tell you what to do but
i know that the behavior i don't wear a
mask when i'm speaking like most
senators
well i'm most sensitive i don't need
your instruction
[Laughter]
i love it i want everyone to wear a mask
he says he fiddles with
it and moves it again while we're
talking about science please
someone find me one scientific research
paper
that tells me your homemade cotton mask
your stupid single ply
cotton mask makes any difference when
not washed
in a hospital commercial washing machine
one mm-hmm
one we'll wait it says right on there
that they're not medical grade that's
the best part it's like this has
nothing to do with medicine no it's more
than this is not intended
to help right in any way is what it says
in the mass not indebted to prevent but
it's like not inten
basically we've lied to you hope you
enjoy your unemployment check
oh yeah in new york they sell the
shields like outside those little
bodegas and everything it's like yeah
this guy's on top of the medical world
go to him yeah get a kebab while you're
there yeah
let's go to the stop shop you need to
wear a mask no it's okay i my hobby is
welding
yeah i'm good you buy girl and back
yes yes that took what 30 seconds
speaking of the girl who was bought and
paid for uh there's been a calling now
from michigan state rep to impeach
governor whitmer
because now she's going to have a don't
say yes if we say that impeachment or
that we support it then that means that
we support her kidnapping and murder
according to the media no no there's a
fight to be really clear
impeach good killing bad very bad yes
don't impeach don't threaten i hope i've
crystallized my thoughts for you can't
do any of it i guess
one is somewhere there's a militiamen
out there going like you said it and
i knew what you were thinking i mean no
it's a dog whistle man i heard it
longhorn dog
exactly what happened to foghorn
lakehorn he was funny with the turkey
and
he was roosting he talks you remember
him i fought him by a pool
yeah yeah all right well you see it's
you sit down i'm gonna go kill the
governor
um i'm on my way so here's the thing
they want to lead you because
three weeks right three week lockdown in
the state of michigan but here's a
little graphic from governor whitmer
uh that says open and i don't know if
you can read that for me because i can't
read it from the monitor can one of you
guys read open
her legs not open wow can you guys see
it no yeah yeah yeah okay there you go
so
uh open to household gathering high
capacity
let's go all right bring it back up this
is a horrible disaster
we got a little preview of it all right
retail open
uh preschool through eighth grade open
manufacturing where people cannot work
from home child care parks and outdoor
recreation not open
high school colleges and universities
for in-person learning workplaces who
can work from home
restaurants indoor dining organized
sports does anyone notice
a glaring omission there what's not on
there
been a hot topic hot topic itself no we
don't want to hear about your corn
t-shirts
we get it it's a collectible they still
have napoleon dynamites
i just hope you're not in it i hope it
gets burned down and then you get burned
later oh um it's uh church
churches shirts there's nothing no
mention of church
not in open or closed you know why or
the chicken
because this broad wants other people to
do her dirty work that's a question that
a lot of people have right
the rebel now is a 75 year old pastor
who's holding small groups and i say
this because i know churches in michigan
that have had their board of elder
busybodies telling them they can't host
small groups of
five or more in their own basements why
is that not mentioned governor whitmer
something about freedom of worship
something about the first time isn't it
something like that i think it's there
i'm not sure anymore though but it
depends on how you interpret the law
freedom
of assembly freedom to worship uh can be
interpreted as freedom to
burn down walgreens and [ __ ] there's
also 12-step
meetings that i go to we'll just call
them that yeah
those also have disappeared a little bit
in the really yeah i mean
i've heard that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i gotta tell
you after this quarantine and lockdown
most of those people are not coming back
especially if you started at the
beginning most of them aren't still
there yeah
most of them are on step zero yeah i
mean earth yeah
they're not going around making their
apologies they're just backsliding
yeah like shadow and homeward bound
liquor stores open
um it really is uh
we have a few things to get to but by
the way hey just let you know before we
move on
um subscribe obviously to the podcast
but we're on parlor now
things aren't going so hot with facebook
we'll have some new announcements but
you can follow stephen crowder on parlor
uh because listen we all know where this
is going and like i said we're going to
be on these territories on youtube
on parlor facebook twitter as long as we
have a voice but facebook is getting to
the point where
we almost don't have a voice still no
answer why they ban the election stream
and of course do support us at mug club
live with cutter.com
mug club uh crowder election stream
still gives you 30 off it is what allows
us to do this show before we move on we
have fraud week by the way we're going
to continue georgia today
i know we're going to do michigan on
thursday i think tomorrow we might have
to hit pennsylvania and wisconsin or
pennsylvania nevada there's so much
fraud it's tough to fit in
um and there i don't care what they're
talking about on cnn
it's like joy behar remove hydration
just bring that up so people get the
reference
hilarious so um
here's oh you know what there's another
story now there was an owner of a bmw
remember who uh
had the racist uh epithets that were
spray-painted all over his car
with a hate crime well it's actually
time for uh this week's installment of
fake hate crimes
[Music]
yes [ __ ]
even with a beasting face audio wave's
really good at that nail gun
yeah um so this is the one it was in
october
the guy said that he had spray-painted
racist and homophobic uh slurs on his
car
but now he might be charged with actual
insurance fraud because turns out
the guy did it himself
here's the clip from local news pa's
office is charged 18 year old clifton
yutzy
you may remember reports back in october
of a man whose suv was spray painted
with racist homophobic and anti-semitic
graffiti
while on saranaca avenue in the city one
of the investigators now believe
it was uc himself who did that to his
own vehicle
faces seven years in prison
he just hates his father and this was
the most painful way he could come out
tell you the general's not going to like
this no
for a good hate crime you can see online
go to the general to save some time oh
no my rate is now 35 dollars
just
[Laughter]
i skyrocketed you can compare rates in
prison uh
so there you go seven years what's the
big deal no no i think it's hilarious
when stuff like this happens when you
get caught for doing this crap
because he's going to go to prison after
advertising basically his car was a rap
telling his future prison inmates that
he's gay
oh it's like i'm coming can you imagine
like a hot ticket you're in the shower
and they're asking
like what are you in for and it's like
murder you know assault i spray painted
my car
yeah some backwards swastikas my car had
a bunch of races
and gay stuff written on it like oh man
that's horrible and then but it turns
out i wrote it
oh it turns out but you wrote it though
yeah it turns out but you
you knew that you wrote it well it turns
out i did write it no it didn't turn out
cause you knew you did write it but i
did
turn it turned out to me that that
happened are you gay yeah i'm gay as
hell and then
it's turned out that was just stuff to
me in this shower yeah
please stop talking i sprayed vote trump
what'd you say
[Laughter]
no like it was supposed to be that they
thought i oh man
i guess i'll go to the marion
brotherhood i don't know
oh man irish spring's so slippery it
must be it's not vegetable
this is one of the most slippery soaps
i'm going to be down here a while yeah
that has been this week's installment of
fake hate crimes
[ __ ] okay
uh question of the day what do you think
is going on in floyd county georgia
we're going to get to that in a little
bit
um and uh have you noticed the
explanation for all these glitches and
there are more glitches
yeah there have been many many glitches
where it's no longer a glitch in the
system it's a feature
um where they always have a fall guy a
patsy
for the higher ups like someone forgot
to upload the clip right it's always
human error
yeah it's always always error but it's
almost like we went to an automated
system like dominion to avoid human
error well
it seems like it might make it worse
it's only the future of our republic uh
let's go to what we talked about whitmer
but uh there's a long list
of uh democrat hypocrites and i know
listen everyone is a hypocrite i
understand that you can point to
christians who are flawed who are
imperfect like hey you
you think that adultery is wrong but you
look at naked pictures okay i got it hey
you
you don't believe in drunkenness but you
got buzz at the christmas party sure
everyone is a hypocrite i understand
that that's not an argument however
when you are legislating hypocrisy that
is detrimental to everyone else's
livelihoods except for your own that is
what we run into here with the current
democratic party
and i know saying are you generalizing
yes because all of them all of them are
a part of this with the exception of
lieberman and even then i don't really
know where he is
he's out oh good question yeah uh
california's going into another
locked where is where is joe liebman
where in the world
is i'm here nobody cares
[Laughter]
um the lawmakers in california they go
into a lockdown they headed to hawaii
with
lobbyists stayed a luxury resort about a
hundred people
what a nice place i attended the
conference on lockdown that's the
benefits
by the way i don't have a problem with
it no because i get and i'm not a
hypocrite because we never shut down we
are not distancing at all
no i just licked dave's headphones he
did oh wow
is that what you want to call it
dave said let me go get my irish spring
this sure is slippery soap
again i dropped my headphones it's such
a bad way to be coy yeah
hey you guys ever had like soap that's
too slippery oh i hate it
yeah it would almost make the guy who's
about to do that tune jail like you know
this is just uncomfortable yeah
you know anymore let me chase you a
little bit
i'm not really i got to feel like i'm
taking it
i play hard to rape i guess whoa dignity
prolapse
can you fake cry just pretend that i
shall water
let me rub some irish spring in your
face there you go makes it may hurt your
eyes
makes it look painful all right do sally
fields oscar speech
not without my irish spring oh all right
uh and also alfred molina is doing hard
time so that all ties together so
chicago mayor lori lightfoot too by the
way let's go through a couple of
hypocrites here
uh of course well first before that
gavin newsom who everyone hates
this is a great clip where he was
actually attending a friend's birthday
party yeah
uh and not just like a birthday party at
a house you know with governor whitmer
two or less which
by the way i guess two or less just
means if you're married that's it
pretty much you're just
yeah you got to make your kids sit
outside sorry kids but that's okay i
don't know if the rule applies to the
tents that you put outside
um so gavin newsom uh attended a
friend's birthday party but wasn't just
a house in a basement it was at an
exclusive
of course posh restaurant as one does a
few weeks ago
i was asked to go to a friend's 50th
birthday friend that
had invite well looks like adam conover
in transition
i need to preach and practice not just
preach and not practice and i've done my
best to do that so when
that happens you gotta you pay the price
but you also
own the mistake and you don't ever make
it again and you have my word on that
ironically preachers in california are
now banned from
you practicing what's so off-putting
about gavin newsom when he's admitting
to a mistake he's smiling
like his robot someone didn't come
someone did the little alien in his men
in black head where they put on the face
mac
face mass didn't tell him like don't
smile he's like so uh i was a hypocrite
and millions are suffering needlessly
and i need to do better so give us some
fake tears something
make me think that you care and don't do
do me a favor don't act like you've
never been to the french laundry that's
the restaurant that he went to in napa
valley a three-star michelin restaurant
it's
tiny you can't get away from people
you're boxed in like sardines look at
him you knew it was gonna happen it's
been the french loan wow i have
one time good for you i didn't like it
that's where you should play it down and
say no i haven't i eat at mcdonald's
i don't want to give the rats yes i went
there effected wino
yeah one of the perks of being in the
wine business don't hate me next time
hold your mug it'll throw some change in
it so
the one quarter seating is still pompous
so then you have chicago mayor lori
lightfoot so what did she do of course
you have the crazy lockdowns in chicago
the record edmond fitzgerald she parted
in the streets
right she partied in the streets at
election uh then she issued a 30-day
stay-at-home order prohibiting families
from gathering in the home which
effectively means that thanksgiving is
cancelled
uh but she was caught on camera here's
how she justified it
well less than a week ago you went out
and stood before
a massive crowd who was celebrating um
joe biden's victory and now you're
saying your city has to shut down how do
you have one and not the other
well look i i think that we've been
saying all along
everybody has to take care everybody has
to take precaution
i will tell you in that big crowd a week
ago we had everybody was wearing masks
look at
you can see the shot here uh mass
compliance in our city
is actually up very very high but yes
there are times when we actually do need
to have a relief
and come together and i felt like that
was one of those times
yeah but she's saying mask wearing was
high except for you so even if that were
true it doesn't matter
but the only reason she had to she had
to address this is because she was
actually captured on camera from a
citizen journalist doing this
even worse she was captured on film uh
in this season's edition of river
monsters so that's something that's yes
that's too bad and uh also uh here's
your new animorphs cover so this is one
that we're just
it's just all it's a genre available
wherever books are sold
it's uncanny the cat that's terrible
that's a fine yes
can't wait she doesn't like beetlejuice
she looks like the howard stern
beetlejuice and the michael keaton
became one person
that's just amazing just imagine
surrounded by likely rioters talking
through a megaphone
with nothing and and she said everybody
was wearing a mask no
i saw like four or five people in that
quick pan that we're not wearing
occasionally though you do need to
release like church
yeah yeah think about that or
thanksgiving no no no no no no no no she
needs a release
you don't she needs a release the
citizens of chicago
let me put this in context really
quickly because i know we're having a
good we're having a good time it's a fun
morning but
our founding fathers left england they
fought them off for less than this think
about it
they fought they were blowing people's
heads off with muskets because they
wanted to add
half a shilling tax to their tetlies and
they're telling you now that you cannot
celebrate christmas or thanksgiving
screw them sorry no i'm not saying go
out there and start using muskets right
no we have far more effective weapons
yeah no but i have the technology
and this might get removed don't comply
if i'm in michigan i wouldn't comply
after thanksgiving have your christmas
if they can go out in the streets and
they can
i tell you what you can comply when
every single
rioter protester in the streets who
commits a crime is behind bars
blaming it how about that yeah yeah and
by the way whitmer as soon as as soon as
you guys are punished for trying to go
and get your boat and go to the lake
house that you own when you told
everybody else in michigan that they
could not do that
then we'll comply if you hold yourself
to the same standard maybe we'll comply
yeah there's also something was it in
michigan where is it you can't let your
pets go out in public
i'm not supposed to let joe lewis go out
no i mean we're having thanksgiving in
michigan and
it's gonna happen yeah i know but that's
because you're a rebel yes well
you're like james dean it's uh yeah
you're gonna drive off a cliff
i'm gonna wear the red jacket and get
beheaded by my convertible
oh well that sucks it's a really bad day
yeah it's not good well it's not a good
thing
[Applause]
what was he quoted to say live like
there's no tomorrow and good thing
yeah good thing the car that i bought
when i bought my first car was a ford
taurus
my second car my first car was a datsun
i bought four thousand dollars from an
old man who had cataracts
it was like brand new showroom new
inside i walk into this
place for my ford taurus a 2004 ford
taurus
and i walk past multi-million dollar
cars one of them someone can
someone can correct me in this one of
the was it a ferrari spider that james
dean had
was it a porsche i don't know but there
were only like 14 made he had a lot 11
and i walked past lot 12. the guy who
owned this old taurus
did custom work and had he was like a
crazy mechanic had this custom shop but
he drove an old tourist
and then he took the bus because he was
like i can drive they said you're blind
he's like
i don't think gosh i'm kicking the bus
just like that yeah so he lied not that
it's necessarily relevant but i tell you
what is relevant it is time
now to get to this installment of fraud
week
[Music]
there you go installments all week by
the way today is georgia
i know thursday's michigan tomorrow's
pennsylvania and another state the best
thing you can do
is comment if you like this segment and
uh let us know what else we should be
looking into so
georgia voter fraud the interesting
thing about this is that it changed last
night
yes it did i had the segment kind of
prepared we run it down because people
say there's no evidence of fraud right
and they want
you know tens of thousands yeah uh we
say people media right media says
there's no evidence but then there was
another change
last night and i want to make sure it
was in floyd county they finished a hand
recount by the way it's not a full
auditing
in georgia it's a bs recount they're not
actually counting signatures on belts so
the fact that they found anything
surprised me
they found whoops another 26 over 2600
votes uncounted votes the vast uh the
significant majority of which of course
went to donald trump yeah
what a coincidence and of course like
all uh georgia counties they use
dominion voting systems dominion voting
systems but
of course they find a fall guy and
according to them just like the glitch
in michigan with the six thousand vote
they said well if someone didn't update
the software in this case they say that
someone quote forgot to upload a memory
card
with the votes hold on a second why do
you need someone to upload a map what is
the point
it's an automated system why don't you
just hand count ballots then at that
point
either you have a foolproof system to
eliminate fraud or you have
people from both parties and
accountability to eliminate fraud
you are a miracle dominion because you
managed to hybridize it
only taking the shitty parts that
guarantee fraud
one director asked for one of the for a
sim card from one of the cameras that
people weren't allowed to use
you're not using them so yeah mind if we
grab that memory card memory card
ups whoops so we have a system is it
better
how do you snap that memory card with
your fingers you have good grip strength
i can rip up a frying pan i want to see
that oh
wow from the 20s it's my job worrying
about this on another guy's back i
already said we're good oh okay
i always notice too there's always a
fall guy do you notice this trend it's
always like oh no it's not the system
because this is we're talking about
another glitch with thousands of votes
and there's never been a there hasn't
been a single one with thousands of
votes to this level
right that has gone in trump's favor so
that's another thing we have the glitch
in michigan right there was also another
one
i think it was in connecticut a
republican just won i don't know if
they're using dominion voter systems
that seat switched we had that person
who conceded in michigan who then won by
a thousand votes that republican would
conceded with a six thousand vote switch
and this is just another example just
last night
2600 new votes found first i don't know
how that happens
well the system didn't count them
because this [ __ ]
didn't upload the card that's your
system
[Applause]
we're supposed to have confidence yes in
the current state of our electorate and
you're like ah
well listen this is the most thing
remember they came up this this was the
most secure election of our lifetime
what if someone forgets the sim card oh
man your hosts were screwed
[Applause]
i'm sorry oh let's see hold on uh biden
is talking about something by just
talking about the task force
hasn't talked about the white house
transition that's right because there
won't be one so
uh this is also important by the way
this number i don't know if you know
it's six percent of the vote from the
county
oh wow right fulton county uh or sorry
this is floyd county floyd county
it's five to six percent they only have
30 something thousand people in the
county
so six percent of the vote i thought
that the media said there's never a
difference in any kind of recount maybe
they use words we showed them on air
maybe four to maybe a hundred votes they
said maybe like point one percent
how about six well how about six percent
keep that in mind that all for uh all
virginia sorry all uh
georgia voting says they use dominion so
in fulton county for example
six percent five to six percent would be
over thirty thousand votes
if it happened in uh cadal county that's
one of the counties that obviously is in
question
twenty two thousand that seems like a
lot and georgia what's the spread down
to sixteen thousand fourteen
thousand that's fourteen i think so we
just let's just assume it's not a glitch
even though these glitches have happened
with this system
across the country the only the only
constant in michigan
in places like wisconsin and is dominion
that's the only constant that we have
but they want you to believe that well
it's actually it's it's a it's a person
who didn't upload the card
right well let's hope that doesn't
happen anywhere else in the united
states i know right and so cnn has spent
all morning and allison camaro even said
they've done this recount and they have
come out in most she said most counties
exactly
the same are you telling me she didn't
have access to this information where
it's 2600 votes
right we're not counted at all period
and by the way you know what's hilarious
the election chair the person sorry the
election director was forced to step
down
and i know that sounds like well okay
that makes sense think about it that
person
was fired from a job they volunteered
for that doesn't exist anymore
it's like don't show up to work i wasn't
there's no work and we're not gonna pay
you didn't pay me anyway
why why are you why are you calling me
this is important i want you to know
matter of fact go piss in that carpet so
i can rub your face in it right yeah
on television but this is a job a
volunteer job that doesn't exist
anymore that's how severe this was yeah
isn't my job like gone and over yes but
we still need you to step down from it
i don't understand we need to blame you
if you could come back and be rehired
for a moment so that we can then fire
you that'd be great
please make us feel good we need to
blame someone specifically
okay yeah we'd prefer you
yeah if you could turn that confused
face into a crying face that'd be
really helpful for us that'd be perfect
come to this shower i'll show you
so they were using dominion again
there's always a following i was a fall
person in michigan there's a
by the way just so you know for some
reason i panicked i thought my gun fell
out of its holster
something fell it was a monitor here or
something okay people are saying that
i'm not practicing good firearms it's
just expensive
it's right here everyone can see it's
okay
uh three other georgia counties by the
way using dominion voting software they
reported glitches so again not the
biggest ones yet but the glitches
spaulding county morgan county gwinnett
county
uh the republican chairman david shaffer
reported fulton county workers by the
way here's another example of something
that went on separate from dominion
reported that uh county workers sent
poll watchers home on election night and
that makes sense because we were
watching election night they said we're
gonna resume counting
at 9 00 a.m and instead they sent poll
watchers home and resumed counting in
secret
that alone is enough to throw out the
vote people understand that alone throws
out the vote because yeah
there's there can be no confidence in it
right if you tell poll watchers to go
home
and you keep counting it's done it's
done that's it yeah yeah
period and i'm sorry you had people that
voted in there that their vote should
count but there are rules for a reason
we have to be able to trust in our
elections and when you violate those
rules you
have to throw out those ballots because
there is no way for us to separate those
and go which ones are real which ones
are not why are you trying to
disenfranchise minorities
no i'm trying to make sure that we have
an accident he defends himself
on you when you defend yourself i am not
just go along with it
otherwise you're a racist i'm not sure
that
makes sense well i am
[Laughter]
the worst thing you can do is defend and
apologize when someone's harassing you
like you're not
yeah there's a racist guy over here no
no no hold on baby
yep yep hey hey tyrone can you talk to
them
[Laughter]
honey road throw away my copies of the
turner diaries
well you're adding all the uh henry ford
documents that we have that he sent to
the uh
those could reflect poorly you know the
ones that i don't agree with
[Laughter]
the ones that i read yeah yeah take
those off of my bedside table
also my reading light for research it's
for research also you know what while
you're at it and play it safe just also
erase the digital copies on my kindle
there we don't know yeah
i don't need that
redundancy something about uploading a
sim card by the way hit the notification
bell if you're subscribed on youtube
because uh
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
notifications let you know when a new
segment goes up and of course we
broadcast live monday through thursday
good morning
club 10 a.m eastern the best thing you
can do is just comment like this video
um and let us know what you think so
here's another uh uh
example of georgia voter fraud moving on
from dominion which again is enough
uh in the june primary secretary of
state brett i always get his name on
brad raffensberger
something i don't know the guy's a dick
he said that a thousand residents voted
twice
by submitting absentee ballots and then
voting in person this was in the june
prime minister that's supposed to be
possible so that happened back then and
now he's saying well you know we're
gonna do the count we're not gonna see
they're not doing an actual audit
there's this is this is
political theater the recount in georgia
if you're going to do a recount do an
actual recount you see wisconsin said
well it's going to cost you over seven
million dollars donald trump if you
wanna
if you want to uh do a recount so one
second you screwed up
isn't that the job like if we're going
to talk about the separation of powers
right and i understand we go back and
forth there should be kind of a
a federal standardized form of voting
because it is a federal election but
they give this authority to states and
counties and they handle them in
different ways but if that is the case
then you should also assume the
responsibility
if there are glitches further than the
eye can see but instead of saying we're
not going to
it's 20 000 votes yeah if there is some
kind of process where you say look there
there have been problems
you have to do a count because of these
irregularities we didn't cause the
irregularities
you did right your county officials did
it's not our fault here's a
number five an example we're going
through voting just voter fraud again
all the links are available at
liveaworthcrowder.com we'll have in the
description we'll have the link to the
specific article so you guys can have
all these sources and share them and
research them for yourselves
uh you know we talked about how
nationally mail-in ballots were accepted
at 30 times the rate yeah
of the 2016 election well in georgia
specifically so in fulton county
they uh they've had a rejection rate of
mail-in balance of only 0.4 percent
0.4 which in a vacuum doesn't sound like
a whole lot
in 2016 it was over 10 times that it was
5.77
which by the way is seven also
percent more likely than you catching
kovid twice
but so the so in other words
throughout history a lot of mail-in
ballots were rejected because they
didn't have signatures right yeah they
were potentially fraudulent
the signatures didn't match but for some
reason now all of a sudden particularly
the ones that come in the dead of night
yeah 10 to 12 times the rate of
acceptance nationally
30 times the rate of acceptance the only
reason that's the case
just to be clear we talked yesterday how
elizabeth warren klobuchar they were all
bitching about voter fraud and the
potential with dominion voter systems
we've talked about this in the past
where there's been a rejection rate
that's always at least in the single
percentages
not in the decimals right always in the
past the only reason that now they're
all being accepted
is because of politicization and they
want you to believe that if all mail and
ballots are not accepted if all absentee
ballots are not accepted if all
unrequested mail and ballots are not
accepted that people's votes don't count
they never cared about it before they
didn't even reque it didn't require it
was never an issue before they have poll
watchers it was never an issue to go oh
this doesn't have the same signature
we're rejecting it
they rejected them at 10 times the rate
in georgia 30 times
nationally yeah and i guarantee you
right now if donald trump was winning by
these slim margins and it was a five
percent rejectance rate they'd be going
back into that and saying no no no you
threw out too many votes of course you
know you got to get that number down
fair game
i think we should be throwing out more
votes oh yeah and i don't believe in
recycling
nope oh jerk worse for the environment
yeah it smells to hot no it's
recycling is more expensive for the
environment it is but you'd be in jail
in california for saying that well i
don't care gavin what's gavin news i'm
going to do take you out today
he's going to duck out of one of his
parties with all those queer party
friends
oh geez they are strange they are very
strange strange
strange people wide open party
that's what happens if gavin newsom
comes knocking on your door can't you
just go what happened to all your queer
party friends
oh fulton county movie
they're inside you can join us there's
plenty of irish spring to go around
limbo in um fulton county by the way
hello they stopped counting fulton
county one of the biggest counties in
georgia we've talked about them before
here's another thing too so we've given
you examples of acceptance rates
rejection rates the glitches and
dominion right that we've seen people
vote twice
uh in the primaries and this is one
that's just kind of fun but it also was
relevant
they stopped counting on election night
uh for
hours because of pipe burst oh no
so sad a pipe first but then when trump
when a doctor
filed a records request they could
provide no official
record of the reason that the voting
stop and this is by the way separate
from the fact that there are certain
machines that just shut down for hours
we've talked about that yesterday
they were able though to clog the pipe
with a ton of trouble
yeah that was what it was yeah they
solved the problem yes
there we go you've heard of ballot
stuffing now we're pipe stuffing
with the stuffing ballots it's like the
inception of stuff and [ __ ]
we fixed two things
uh a bird in the hand is better than
than
two bushes that hold first by the way no
they so there was no official records of
the pipe bursting
that was the excuse they gave so these
are some information this is some
information the media will never take
like i don't know
that's kind of that enough to me is
evidence of fraud if you had someone
watching your house
right and you came home and your house
was absolutely destroyed and there was
water damage
you said what happened they said a pipe
burst you're like oh
i'm gonna and there then there's no
actual pipe that's burst you find out he
just fell asleep drunk in the bathtub
and flooded your top floor which did
happen to me
thanks jeff you would be suspicious
but we have journalists on the ground
and actually we do have the exclusive of
um
oh i want we want to be fair and
balanced pipe did burst we have the
um exclusive that's lots of water you'll
never get back
well shot yeah i think it's totally
believable
oh my god it's about as believable as
what they sent
oh yeah yeah yeah it's like what is hold
on a second pipe burst i don't see any
kind of a font but something about
slick shoes what is this any clip from
problem child would seem equal yes
look who's talking three yeah by the way
here's something else too this is
something that hasn't been reported a
lot and this is
this is circumstantial but uh you can
find this at town hall again you can
find it louder with crowder all the
links that will be provided on the
website
during a recount there was a monitor who
heard three miscalled votes
in three minutes all of them were trump
votes for biden
so this person watched someone you know
they call them out and go biden
biden zone zone biden and the person
wait hold on
that's that that's for trump and the
person went around to whatever it was
the election director said hey
there are some issues going on here so
the election director went over and
spoke to this one this person said
i'm on the taxpayer dime and this
[ __ ] is coming around watching me
almost like we need to keep our
representatives accountable
you know so three times and again no
example now if
there were any stories coming from the
left none any any stories of counters
out there
ballot counters people pro any stories
people on the left anyone out there cnn
brian stelter anyone on
i guess there's really no leftists on
youtube or were the adversaries anymore
but anyone have stories of someone
calling out trump when it was a biden
vote
three times in three minutes let us know
and in the in the middle of the night at
4 45 in the morning which is
that's a lot of minutes yes it is yes it
is yeah and you know
it's like rollover minutes well and
somebody was 20 feet away steven it's
fine
20 feet away yeah you can totally call
that out binoculars they're good
yeah we should pay these people oh
i think people many of them are paid by
the democratic party
that's true good point not so much paid
as they are rewarded in blunt
tools that's true to inflict trauma in a
box of bricks
but what do you what i mean when people
say no evidence we're about to say
they're
gonna say now we know why they were so
mad at the russians because hacking our
elections is their job
[Applause]
well maybe i wouldn't have to do your
job if you did properly first time
like a mistress maybe i wouldn't have to
please your man if you could too
better sort of counterclockwise swirl he
likes it
oh wow the whole thing goes inside mouth
wow
[Laughter]
which is ironic because you americans
are one with big mouth but we know how
to keep secrets
i wait in breadline as little girl for
hour
still speak like a man i wait for two
weeks
to get non-stretch lois jeans
they look good look
good they come up to over my navel
i will play hockey and slice throat
[Laughter]
high sticking it's all high sticking
when we play in soviet russia no it's
true this is amazing they talk about
russian interference in the election
people were furious for 3
000 ads to the tune was it 3 000 ads to
the tune of 10 000
or something like facebook ads last
election that's all they had by the way
no connection to the trump family
no but in this case you have thousands
of votes that
what and this this is an example people
before the glitch was caught in michigan
with six thousand votes well
on a second that may have only been
caught because of an honest elector by
the way who was going
up going against the stream against the
system of people who were trying
to suppress votes of people who were
trying to stuff ballots and this person
wasn't there at 4 45 in the morning god
only knows if there was anyone there at
that point but now here in georgia
we actually have an example of this only
being caught
from a recount that isn't even really a
total canvas or auditing right
exactly and so the whole point of this
is that when you have an irregularity
and that's why we bring it up so many
times
that is a sign that you need to
investigate to make sure that you catch
these kinds of things
when i see cnn and jake tapper tweeted
out something the other day there was
like what a couple hundred votes in
arizona that switched
and he was like yeah so he still won
arizona by like you know whatever 15 000
votes and i'm like that's not the point
the point is they shouldn't switch right
they shouldn't switch in the first place
this is just what we caught
and yeah do you know how we know they
shouldn't switch or at least why we
thought they shouldn't switch
you told me you told me jake that
recounts are just an exercise in
futility that you said
0.1 to maybe 0.4 percent historical you
use the words
for to i don't remember something
hundred so maybe it might switch like
four
to maybe like something what do you mean
twenty six hundred
yeah six thousand and again this is not
one that was caught
before the election was called which by
the way is already preemptively called
this is one that was only caught after
when there was a recount and they've
done everything possible to make sure
that there is no accountability in this
recount
so what does it take when people say
there's no evidence what do you mean
there's no evidence that someone is
it has a has a stick and a handkerchief
in his right riding the trails
riding uh right riding the trains right
or with your ballots like what is it
is this not proof yeah several thousand
that just got
found nothing in the media think about
what
i guess my question is what does it take
if not thousands in different counties
and different states
what does it take at this point where
you say we we hand recount
every single county in the united states
period here's what it takes apparently
nothing
yeah yeah and really it just seems that
they don't care what it takes several
hundred thousand that you have to find
which by the way you'll never be able to
find because they won't allow you to do
the recounts like this was accident and
they really didn't want us to find
anything
2600. you know when they heard 2600
someone went [ __ ]
yeah exactly you know what it takes it
takes joe biden losing
that's what it takes yeah the media to
push this for anybody to push a recount
it takes joe biden losing and them
saying no that's not real
right this can't happen again or out or
al gore in florida right think about
like kevin coster that hbo documentary
on the whole recount thing yeah and they
never tell you they had 37 days
and al gore only wanted to recount three
they're like okay you want to do a
recount in florida all right we'll do it
and then he's like no no i just want to
do miami-dade
and this county and like well hold on we
should do all kinds of no no no no we
just want to recount three families
this one and this one like well if we
count the other ones i think this isn't
going to go well for you i would say
that's circumstantial
just three counties and we didn't hear
about the end of it you weren't talking
about not accepting an election they
still haven't accepted the results of
the 2000 election
hillary clinton i don't believe has
conceded yeah she still hasn't even sent
out a proxy to concede
and she's told uh biden not to concede
no matter what right that's
the deal the the that what that changed
the minute that oh it did
lost it changed it changed at the same
time when they said it's going to take
months to know the results
right and all of it changed at about 4
44 a.m
yeah three days in a row with a graph
that was doing this and then went
for joe just that is put this you want
to talk about no accountability with the
poll watchers now democrats well
actually poll watchers were allowed but
if they can't see it look
it doesn't matter yeah we this is this
is the media right this is an
entertainment show politics of course
but this is this is media okay so we
were covering the election more people
were watching it here than on any of the
main networks that night certainly on
their online streams right it was
unbelievable we thank you so much for
incredibly appreciative crazy we didn't
have we weren't granted the ability to
cover
the election we were all strapped in to
do it all night until the results
the only reason that we called it was
because they said all right we're not
gonna do any more counting
we're gonna start at 9am so we the media
weren't allowed access and that just
means
an up-to-date count you told us it was
shutting down and you started it back
an hour and 15 minutes later so why
would we believe that you actually want
transparency in the process and had any
poll watchers
because we weren't allowed to do our job
yeah exactly i find that nothing strange
happens in the middle of the night when
you swear you're not doing anything
wrong
especially in detroit or flint right
never seen it
never done it myself they do their best
work at night best work
oh yes it's always good oh my god hi
class you know this is just where
we will be continuing through the states
i think tomorrow i know we have
pennsylvania i don't think
that's wisconsin pennsylvania and friday
sorry thursday is michigan because you
and i are both from michigan
what surprised me most about michigan is
not only the counties that were entirely
red before that went blue
but some of the really red counties and
you look at those margins
yes where donald trump won by a very
slim amount in a county that was you
know
70 80 donald trump and he's barely you
can buy with like 58 percent
michigan i'm gonna get a little nerdy
and granular because people well
michigan's you have to write michigan
off because it's a couple hundred
thousand votes but when you actually get
into the numbers
it's clear that something more sinister
has been going on in michigan because it
doesn't track
with any of our previous elections in
michigan and by the way that also means
the elections that democrats have won
just to be clear yes yeah absolutely so
well and by the way
post inauguration no matter who is put
in as president if it's joe biden or
donald trump this fight needs to
continue
and it's not necessarily to overturn the
election right so if we all said okay
fine fine
whoever you want in the president the
oval office right now fine i'll concede
that can we make sure
i'm not going to i'm saying what if can
we just make sure this doesn't happen
again
that's my goal my goal is to make sure
no i'm not really you're ready to
contact because you're a [ __ ] boy
i'm defending myself again aren't you oh
you did it are going to defend yourself
[ __ ] but getting mad
right we just have to make sure this
doesn't happen again period everybody
should be on board for that
is that true possibility i think so okay
hey hey who's the boy
he looked at me he looked at me at that
point he looked at me you hear him say
he was
i hate everybody no really but in
michigan it was all red
i mean and even cnn announced how
detroit had flipped and
you know county at least which people
look at wayne county and they think just
detroit
it's not right there's a huge amount of
republicans in that
entire county i thought you were saying
they think it's detroit and detroit is
not detroit because that is also
accurate well yes just a few crackheads
and then a couple hipsters with coffee
shops you think they're going to save it
until all of a sudden there's an
epidemic of hipster rape and then they
go away
well yeah it's people with urban farms
who get stabbed by the locals and
they're like
they took all my plums
i'm not leading these pumps yeah free
food
i don't know what you got a pumpkin
you expected to have turnips for the
taking in the southeast side
and knocking instead that's on you come
on man
that's all you man why people are stupid
as hell man we just wanna cut give you
some of them gourds
[Laughter]
i need to decorate squash pumpkin
anything in the gourd variety i want
that [ __ ] seasonal how do you make one
of the big horn things with corn in it
the horn with all the fruit coming out
of it does it come like that does it
grow with the fruit coming out you got
to put the food in that [ __ ] i want that
[ __ ]
well it's like an ice cream cone with
fruit yeah
and sometimes there's little letters in
there too yeah my auntie
i love that [ __ ] yeah take that out here
before i shoot you anyway oh yeah i'm
gonna cut your eyes
i hope you don't like talking
uh all right let's move on thank god
let's go to by the way this is cnn do
you notice this is also something that
should be pretty telling a talk about
coronavirus hospitalizations reach
all-time high
that number has been ticking up
incredibly slowly as far as deaths yeah
yes was it what was it 2 30
months ago months ago which really when
you think about a flu season
right that would be tracking slowly for
a flu season they always talk about
hospitalizations or they talk about
cases
but they don't talk about deaths because
surprisingly in some areas deaths are
actually going down yeah or the trend
has been stagnant
that's the number that really matters if
you're going to shut down the economy
right in a way that leads to more deaths
through substance abuse suicide
or people starving because they can no
longer actually uh
create a livelihood for the family yeah
especially yeah when you're trying to
scare people saying it's over 90
occupancy well you know what the
hospitals call that good
they they thrive on beds being full they
don't want you to be sick but they're
not going to build a hospital with ten
thousand more beds than they need well
they didn't
see these
yeah they have policy where if you come
in contact with anybody with covid they
have to send you home for 14 days
so their staff members aren't there so
then they have less staff so
they're over like right so they can't
[Laughter]
we go home george clooney really i guess
you have dr house just going well it's
the first thing that's ever got me
wait three days this one will make me
sober up yeah
what's what's the mortality rate it's uh
actually
point zero three percent my god
get my cane my alcoholism is not going
away anytime
soon nor this gruff demeanor more people
bought my blues album
um okay let's move on here to uh it's
just amazing that they're talking about
oh fouchy what is fauci saying really
quickly before we move on this guy
this cena's jessica and she's following
oh okay never mind cena's not actually
just doing news they're re-running clips
that have been circulated on social
media
effectively then telling you that you
need real news which you know they
they're doing less than we do
everyone anyone able to research the
sources on cnn anyone able to go to
cnn.com right now and see what sources
they are listing
no no no nothing so go to liverpool.com
because at least we're trying to keep
ourselves accountable sometimes we get
it wrong dave almost always gets it
wrong
usually yeah that's part of his charm
that's what i do
so here's another thing biden if he's
going to be president we'll go through
all his executive orders right that he's
talking about coming and he's going to
reverse the reversal of the rehearsal of
the mexico city policy basically one of
his first actions is to guarantee that
your tax payer
tax dollars fund abortion overseas
that's his priority
yeah fantastic but another thing on
monday chuck schumer suggested and biden
i i wanted to pull a clip of biden
agreeing but he it was nonsensical when
he was asked the clip
made no sense you'd be more confused
than my description of what i think
biden meant to say
so let me just give you a synopsis so
eloquent
is not going to make it for a term if he
actually becomes president
for a week and a half it's not going to
make it through the inaugural speech
come on so chuck schumer says he will
make
during his assignments he might make in
his pants
chuck schumer suggested biden should
forgive students the first fifty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
with an executive order
now um here's the thing that people
don't understand about this people think
oh that sounds great
student student loans right most people
watch this who got in protest and go ah
i'm bogged down with student loans um
you should be you made bad choices not
everyone
but most of you oh bogged down with
student loans says nobody who
aced their way through medical school
residency and then actually fulfilled
their chosen profession that's not what
happens
same thing if you go to law school in
general underwater basket weaving gender
studies
you might be out there at a bernie rally
i understand where you're coming from
i'm just i'm trying to walk a mile in
your shoes
but they're toms so
here's something people understand the
highest income households in the united
states owe 60 percent of student loan
debt
while the lowest income households owe
less than 20 percent of outstanding
student loan debt because lower income
households
they typically either go to a community
college a trade school or get something
known as a
scholarship the people who have crazy
student loan debt are people who shift
their majors every three years from
german poetry to gender studies to
afro-lesbian studies which is actually
an actual thing
in michigan it is and then all of a
sudden you find yourself sick you find
yourself accounting for 60 percent
of the student loan debt think about
this for a second this is effectively a
handout
to the wealthy the major 56 percent of
student loan that is for graduate school
unbelievable you should yeah 56
of student loan debt we have this is
from the brookings institute is for
graduate school
most people with advanced degrees who
owe a lot they should they should pay it
off easily
unless it's a useless degree right
exactly so i i don't understand
how the government creates this problem
where they say hey come get loans
everybody they're really easy to get you
probably shouldn't be getting this in
the first place
then tuition goes up because there's too
much free money and then people can't
pay back their loans because they get
terrible degrees and the government's
like well we caused this problem but
we're going to take money from you well
this is a perfect example of what what
about looking out for the middle class
right this is joe biden says oh you know
the people i know who worked hard in
scranton scranton
he hasn't seen scranton in 65 years he
had to say it every day
okay and by the way i don't think there
is a boxing club in scranton he made it
up just like amy
he does watch the office he does yeah i
bet you he's the only person
who was from scranton who wouldn't even
catch a dunder mifflin reference but
that's just because he's a demented old
circus monkey that's true
he probably did watch it and he has no
recollection of it where's this again
i like that michael scott guy reminds me
of a young me
promising yes hello could someone get me
his number i'd like to tell him i see a
lot of me and you
mr scott just stay in your basement all
right another handout for the wealthy
right we talk about the the nafta the
north american free trade agreement you
look at joe biden's policies and barack
obama's policies and you look at the
unemployment rate in the united states
you look how it affected black american
families you look how the average
household income only went up by a
thousand dollars in eight years under
obama
and then you look at five thousand on
average under the first term of donald
trump
and you look at this and people say oh
hot suns people shouldn't have student
debt well first off
incorrect people should have student
debt if they go to schools
and they decide to procure a degree that
is useless or that costs a lot of money
anyone can go to a community college
and anyone can get their grades up and
get a scholarship i i know a kid who was
a pothead
loser in high school sorry jordan
sorry he's a he's a harvard law grad
he's he's the guy who bill uh bill was
introduced by this guy yeah it's a
friend
he was a pot head burnout then he met a
wonderful woman who he's married to now
said you're gonna get your crap together
went to community college got straight
a's went to ut got straight a's then
went to harvard
on some kind of a sk he had some kind of
a grant or scholarship because an
outstanding student
got straight a's graduated [ __ ] laude
this is a kid who came from a rough
background from a poor background
and he was already behind the eight ball
because he was doing nothing but
skateboarding and smoking weed
all day now i know the potheads out
there are going to get mad i'm not
saying that everyone smokes a pothead as
a burnout loser though you probably are
if you're offended by this and you're
going to comment in the section
yeah i don't think you already smell it
i don't think you're one of the high
functioning executives who occasionally
dabbles in tincture
i think that you are what we're talking
about
well some of us went to lansing
community college and sold drugs and
paid off their tuition in fives and tens
and that's called america yeah
it really does bother me though it's
like you don't have to go to college no
this is your choice
be responsible for the decision that
you've made
to do this with your life imagine that
pitch at shark tank uh what are
well with those kinds of numbers you
must have some sales i do four hundred
thousand dollars to the junkies
michigan state exactly yeah people
shouldn't have trust
people shouldn't have student debt well
then don't sign for the loan right right
exactly but here's here's the thing
they'll actually postpone your loan
repayment if you go
and get another loan to get an advanced
degree so once you graduate four years
if you go to a master's program
and take out even more money you can
delay your payments it's like reese and
malcolm middleton is paying off credit
cards with other credit yeah exactly
everyone thought he was doing well until
they showed up and they found out
you're paying off mastercard with visa
yeah no it's more like when a
bookie shoots off your toe
[Laughter]
exactly only birdie comes and reattaches
it let me help you with that
yeah like oh my gosh i just it is
this is a perfect example of it sounds
good on paper what the media does is try
and say oh look this will help people
of color this will help the the
disenchanted minorities in this country
who need a leg up
they are not the people who are
incurring most of the student loan debt
it's usually people who come from well
to do families who decide to go into
useless degrees and fields and for some
reason now you
the working class american citizen who
did not impale yourself on the spike of
student debt
you are going to be the one left with
the bill you're going to foot the bill
for uh for for for courtney who decided
to go get a german dance a german dance
degree
that's what this forgiveness is you
working and you wonder why the union
members not the union leaders not the
union actual representatives but people
who are members of unions in the midwest
overwhelmingly voted for donald trump
because these people are working on the
assembly line
and then they they're talking about
under this this potential president
depending on the state up to 62 marginal
tax rates
paying for kids who are getting degrees
in gender studies and poetry and
philosophy
of course that plays poorly with the
american public and that's why it's
remarkable
that joe biden could win an election the
only reason that he would be able to is
because the media never talks about this
because he doesn't speak the language of
the middle class he hasn't seen scranton
also
he didn't win the election hmm that's
true it has not been called yet
well he also came to detroit and sternum
poked a line worker
yeah that's right and called him a
couple of people fat along
the way yeah that's just the way you're
really a man of the people
he really is yes that's really the
democrat calling card emmanuel in the
shower doing sternum poke and then joe
biden it's like ah that's good
it's like it's like their thumb yeah the
podium with the speech for some reason
poke people in the sternum yeah
hey dog face pony soldier if i were the
dog face but you know it would have been
the best response from that guy like you
dog face pony soldiers last one
i don't know what that means yeah that's
a little that's it
yeah i'm sure there's a coalition of
dog-faced ponies so yeah i'm very upset
about it
the facebook group probably you know by
the way this i just want to
point out like this
i think i dated one this is i love that
he's blowing like all of his political
capital on
treating a symptom and not the disease
again so what happens when you pay off
the
let's just do the math you pay it off
let's find do that what about 10 years
from now
when you have another group of people
that have the exact same problem because
you didn't solve
what was causing the problem in the
first place which is increased tuition
cost well now they're going about you
how about you put your money give me
money
right yeah yeah how about you put your
money into that not only that
this will make it worse let me allow me
to allow me to sort of help you follow
the money trail okay
all right here's timmy he's getting a
degree in afro-lesbian-centric studies
okay
afro-lesbian funk okay oh yeah
he gets alone here's here's the two
universities here's timmy
okay so you know what here let's let's
uh let's move this this
is timmy this is the university this is
the loan yeah all right
so timmy wants to go to the university
and get a degree in uh afro-lesbian funk
okay he gets a loan from the bank and
that gets paid to the university
right at this point and of course that's
paid with interest the university gets
the money
this money has already gone through so
now timmy has a useless degree and he's
in debt and what's going to happen is he
owes the bank the university already has
the money
now what they're going to do is absolve
him of his debt by giving this money to
the bank what do you think happens with
that school
we got away with that one let's charge
more money next time yeah there's a lot
more people that can afford
what do we charge him we charged him 50
000 so we could make make up the
difference with
an out of state grant all right let's
charge them 75 000. the government's
going to step in and pay it anyway
stupid factory worker shouldn't have
gone to trade school [ __ ] think about
that for a second
it's going to make it worse of course
that's going to cause inflation there's
no reason for schools to compete
and bring down tuition costs the idea of
forgiving student loans
encourages the actual now people use the
term predatory lending right with banks
where it's like
now this again the problem there when
all of these scenarios the same thing
with school tuition
in every scenario when you look at out
of control inflated costs
what you find is government
interventionism
okay look at the interest insurance yep
right airlines
uh uh student loans right when you deal
just any kind of medical any kind of
medical issue
do you want you want to tell me that
those are on energy those are
unregulated industries
for crying out this always makes it
worse what makes it worse when you say
oh everyone has to purchase health
insurance we're going to punish them
we're going to
we're actually going to charge you a
fine if you don't purchase health
insurance
by the way health insurance you have to
accept anyone's pre-existing conditions
right oh good well then at that point i
guess could do we uh we but is there
like a limit on the rate we can charge
no no limit okay
20 000 a month thanks fed what do you
think happens
with with uh houses people say predatory
lending
all right the government steps in and
says you are going to lend this money to
these people who cannot afford this
house right that's not really what we do
here at this bank of
making money oh really well here's the
thing if they can't actually pay you
back uh we're going to give you the
money all right
sold well it's like they're explaining
explaining to insurance people what
insurance is and then insurance people
are like no the
you can't accept people with
pre-existing yeah that's not interesting
no no no
yeah okay and then we'll pay the bill
and then you go to schools so we have
homes we have insurance and now we have
schools
if they go to kids where they go okay
listen so uh if
school let's say you can you can afford
what ten thousand dollars all right
we're gonna charge fifty thousand
dollars because uncle sam was
nonetheless
are a bunch of grants and scholarships
that we can find to make up that
difference
there's an incentive to make school
unaffordable
otherwise you're leaving tens of
thousands of federal dollars
on the table in all of these scenarios
it's the government coming and by the
government i mean the taxpayer's dime at
which joe biden has suckled at the teat
upon the team of the taxpayer for 67
years now at this point
they're the ones who come in and they
say oh you know we'll just pay for
timmy's afro lesbian funk degree
and what happens inflation out of
control you saw it with home mortgage
you saw it with homes people getting
homes they couldn't afford
yeah with insurance premiums and
deductible skyrocketing and you see it
with student loan costs what you have to
do
is actually stop subsidizing these
schools
and their predatory rates these people
are taking advantage of students by
charging them more than they can afford
because the federal government makes up
the gap that's where it's predatory
not banks being forced at a gun of
bernie of uh uh
fannie mae freddie mac to give a house
to someone who can't afford it i don't
care what the big short term yeah
absolutely and if you if you had a plan
for actually solving this problem it
would include something like hey maybe
we shouldn't tell everybody that they
should go to college maybe you do need
to go to a trade school maybe you need
to go get a job and do something else
maybe you can't afford to pay back this
loan well all they have is fifty
thousand dollars
how are you that's that's still how are
you gonna indoctrinate them with marxism
everyone has to go to college that is
true i mean loud with a lesbian afro
studies degree you do have to learn how
to throw a molotov cocktail at a police
car
oh that's a second year i think yeah
that's true let's send you to uh you
have everyone has to go to college and
we're going to subsidize it well you
know i don't want to go to college i
think i can actually learn myself you
know with uh used to be 85 cents and
late visit a public library right now
it's just a
carpal tunnel because i can run a search
oh and by the way we're going to make it
so that when you search
you don't find points of view that
aren't expressed in universities
we're going to we're going to shut down
alternative news sources so you either
go to school
where a a huge percentage a majority of
colleges have
no conservative leading professors
whatsoever let alone the humanities
programs
or if you don't go to school we're going
to make sure that this vast information
superhighway which effectively has
replaced
school and we now know this because of
online learning with kovid right good we
don't need schools anymore governor
whitmer said so but
don't expect them to hand back any of
their money so if you stay home and you
learn from home and you use something
called the internet well now
we will make sure that the internet does
not provide you with any information
that we do not want you
reading what an absolutely brilliant
racket and that's why i say
you know what it starts with the mask
and not having thanksgiving
i will not comply we're gonna play uh
bad movie lines and take your chat
exclusively for people who are watching
on youtube or listening on audio
uh about another 30 minutes of show here
with dave landau and gerald a
youtube it's time for you to i always
have like when i talk
piss off youtube
you